day four of the Invictus games is
underway this morning in Toronto Prince
Harry created the annual sports
competition for injured veterans the 33
year old royal and his girlfriend
American actress a megan merkel made
their first public appearance together
yesterday and they were spotted holding
hands very the couple watched events on
the tennis court in front of Toronto
City Hall and that's where Jeff Glor is
Jeff good morning good morning Prince
Harry and Megan marquel watched
wheelchair tennis here in this square as
we did yesterday we also got a chance to
watch Track & Field and met a couple
American athletes who like everyone here
are inspiring folks well beyond Toronto
I was a medic from was 13 years with
82nd airborne out of Fort Bragg North
Carolina and jumped out of airplanes
three deployments and I knew that I
wanted to continue to help individuals
so I decided to go the nursing route
Kelley M wingers illness and injury
happened back at home while still on
active duty a rare form of cancer took
the lower half of her left leg and I
told my providers as soon as I was
diagnosed I don't care what you do to my
leg just continue to allow me you know
to be a mom and I'm still a mom with a
daughter here with a daughter here at
the Invictus games this year as in
athletes and single mother to nine
year-old Jaden L Molina has already
earned four gold medals in track and
field I was injured in Afghanistan
August 31st 2010 by ie D Anthony
McDaniel is one of Elm lenders friends
and a Team USA teammates a triple
amputee he competes in four sports but
wheelchair basketball and wheelchair
rugby are his specialties
is there a sport you wanted more in I
won't rugby in basketball pretty equally
especially because um I've been getting
a lot of chatter from Great Britain
Great Britain's trash-talking oh of
course that's what they do the innocent
fun enjoy here seems almost entirely
disconnected from any division below the
border for the athletes and the kids
watching it's not a bad place to be
I'm happy to be an inspiration to a lot
of kids and you know just to be one of
the guys that they see that you know
don't give up because that's meaningful
for them when they see you out there
doing what you're doing yeah I've got
enough negative things around so it's
like we need that positive you know and
they need it what does it mean to have
your daughter here with you quite a bit
I'm rather proud of her because she
doesn't see injury she doesn't see
illness she doesn't see missing legs
these games aren't about the medals
these games are about the lies that you
change for her to see a person for who
they really are and not what they're
missing that right there is really what
these games are about Kelly is still set
to compete in swimming Anthony's the
events wheelchair rugby and wheelchair
basketball come up on Wednesday and
Thursday and we cannot wait to see how
they do
Gail you are so right Charlie just said
oh boy you're right Geoff we can't wait
to see how they do as you pointed out
nor it's always important to pay tribute
to these athletes who have given so much
of the country but I love Kelly's line
about I don't care what you have to do I
just still want to be a mom whatever you
have to do to do that for me you know
think about this discussion that with
this larger discussion we're having
sports as a unified that's right it's
also a healer right you know and for
many of these veterans who have lost
limbs competing once again not only
lifts them physically but lifts their
spirits give some pride and purpose yeah
and it's wonderful to see it I'm a huge
huge supporter of that I'm glad Jeff's
been doing all that great reporting you
too thank you Jeff Thor from Toronto